what is it that makes a character boring
to you I think a character with no inner
life I think is boring you know I think
if I think if for me I think if the
character is having some inner life if
that makes sense you know whether that
inner life is subtext or whether that
inner life is in conflict with his
public life or her public life you know
that's interesting to me you know I
don't know I think it really depends on
the kind of story it is and you know you
know every I guess you know to use a
comparison to like making a meal I think
every meal is different you know every
meal demands different kind of
ingredient you know and so I certainly
don't feel like I have all the answers
by any means you know I mean for me I'm
just trying to figure things out on my
own and I'm trying to figure things out
on my own
based on my own kind of sensibilities in
my own you know way of writing but I
think
I think having some in our life you know
is um what about you I'm even thinking
it let's suppose a movie that's light
and fluffy like Legally Blonde it was
still interesting her character right is
still you want to see her she doesn't
seem to get easily you know taken aback
by all sort of these jobs that are
thrown her way like and you're kind of
like wow that's really interesting it
keeps being light and bubbly and happy
most people would be like giving these
people the middle finger after a while
you know but and so you're kind of like
wow I find you're interesting you know
and that's that's a light you know fun
film but there's kind of a message
behind it but still it's a studio sure
and where it wasn't boring you're right
interesting enough to keep my attention
and I mean that's I mean it's incredibly
crafted screenplay mm-hmm well you know
I mean on a plot level in terms of where
things happen on in terms of you know
when you're talking about the
traditional you know having the first
kind of like pre life and how that
changes what what it is fighting you
know incident you know all that stuff
but you know you love her character I
mean she's battling against kind of
expectations that people have you know
with who she might be and and what her
kind of inner life might be so I think
for me you know that I mean there are
plot driven stories in their character
driven story and you know I think they
certainly kind of like overlap in a lot
of areas but but generally speaking if
you're talking about a character for me
if there's something about that
character that tells me that either that
person isn't telling everything about
his life or her life or there's
something about that person that what he
or she is doing you know in front of
people is different from what they're
doing behind the scenes
for me that's interesting
you